[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking
down Invincible season 2 episode 2 is
now out and it's packed with Easter eggs
comic but callbacks and lots of things
going on in it throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
and going over our thoughts on the entry
as a whole when we last left Mark we saw
as he felt he was becoming his worst
nightmare which is that he was going to
become his dad was something that could
be the case too as in the alternate
universe we saw that he joined them in
this universe though he's out there on
his own and we see as he attends his
graduation just by himself now this took
place during issue 17 with Mark's hat
being thrown in the air above all the
others Man actually launched it up into
the sky and it came crashing down in
England which was a call back to an
earlier joke when Mark got his powers
during issue one he two launched the
burgar garbage bag up into the sky this
also Came Crashing Down on England like
like what the hell mate and we'd learned
a cult had formed around a guy talking
about what was really going on with it
these things being thrown happen in two
transformative moments in his life with
the first being him getting powers and
now his graduation interestingly the
comics had this happening before he went
to Mars whereas in the show it happened
during season 1 now both the show in
comics Mark shows up late but here we
get the reason with it being doc seismic
man's holding up the Washington Monument
riffing on how he held up Mount Rushmore
in season 1 I believe in the comics MC
second appearance was an issue 36 so
there were bits in between like spin-off
things and but at this point he was
tackled by the Guardians of the globe
rising from the ground with the
underdwellers we saw him coming face to
face within season 1 he's come back to
claim the stone structures of Earth
seismic is able to blast out seismic
shocks from his wrists which in many
ways mimics the villain the Shocker
pulling his magman knites out from under
the ground these two debut during issue
36 it Heats things up and to a rousing
graduation speech by principal Winslow
it it just delivers it perfectly without
testing your limits you will never know
how strong you truly
are this battle at the monument is of
course reminiscent of Spider-Man
homecoming and like the Webhead Mark
manages to push through now what this
shows is that he's far stronger than he
ever thought he could be and the things
he thought were limit are no longer the
case man's vomite DNA is getting
stronger and stronger and this will
improve his abilities the longer that he
lives his age Jing also slowing down too
meaning that he's going to live for
thousands and thousands of years now
everyone goes up to accept their
diplomas is it diplomas is it in America
um with Mark's full name finally being
revealed Marcus Sebastian
Grayson in the comics it was William who
made fun of him oras here Amber gets the
jabbin you of course get your full name
read out on your wedding day and the PA
doing this sort of play into the
plotline lighter that happens with the
fish people in that we see Sebastian
going under the sea hey and we'll talk
about how wildly that differs from the
comics Amber's name Justine is dropped
there too with Mark
saying just like what he says in the
comics now we could Eve's Treehouse
which Amber and Mark ended up visiting
in the source material this was all the
way out in Africa whereas here it's in a
US Forest to keep things more localized
they all start talking their plans with
Eve saying she's going to help finish up
the Reconstruction in Chicago it's
something I could hit a bit close to
home cuz Mark was obviously the reason
that it happened clearly he's distant
from the group but we learn he's on call
hence why he's not drinking man's really
thrown himself into protecting the
planet because he wants to be as far
away from what his dad was cut over to
the USSA which is where we catch the
aftermath of the Mars mission this bit
riffs on the moment from issue 22 in
which we saw NASA debriefing all the
astronauts they kind of revers the order
that we have here with him initially
being in the bathroom before going to
the board either way in both he then
gets let go with him struggling to keep
his form together this bit please don't
kill me what spare me that's in the
source material too worrying that he's
going to get executed but effective
immediately you're taking a temporary
leave till you can get your head on
straight and obviously you know when
you're writing when you're adapting for
a series you have to kind of move things
about a lot I know the comics happen in
different orders it was there any point
where you were kind of
like I I need to put this bit in this
season even though it comes much later
down the line we need to have this in
because it's such a powerful moment yeah
I mean I think that happened a little
bit more in season one than in season
two we had to do a little more
rearranging in season one uh but
generally what happens like Robert and I
sit down early on in the in the process
and we look at the comics you know and
we look at where we left off and then we
kind of try to find the spot that we
think is a great emotional place to end
a season on we put that in place and
then we started through the comics we
start to build out everything in between
the start and the end we try to see what
feels natural um obviously we try to
follow the books as closely as we can
that's our road map but there are cases
where you want to move stuff around a
little bit for emotional impact or for
plotting impacts I mean obviously like
comic books you know have issues we have
episodes and you know issues end
sometimes in a big moment you want your
television episode to sometimes end on a
big moment but we only have eight
episodes you know eight hours of comic
series like we might cover 20 issues you
know in a season or more or less um so
you're just trying to find natural
places that that just the stories line
up with our episodes and things kind of
fall into place it's a really organic
process uh and it changes like you know
we we cover a different amount of
episodes than we did in season one and
uh that's going to change again for
season three and I would you know assume
beyond beyond it's just like some
Seasons want to run a little quicker
through the books some want to run a
little slower it's just we just figure
that out as we sit down and start to do
it now back in Chicago we see Eve trying
to fix things which shows her
humanitarian side playing out kind of
reminded me a bit of the Titan Arc in
the first season where we could see was
helping out the tenants unfortunately
you sees firsthand that even with good
intentions things don't always work out
and later on we see the damage that's
caused by her just trying to help takes
what could have been a pretty simplistic
plot and turns it into the Shades of
Gray that you'd always expect from the
show even the vites yet they think their
invasion's in the right and that they're
helping our Earth by putting us under
their rule Eve is sort of in a similar
vein with her powers leading to more
issues than what was there before now
Mark and Debbie's house we see the house
hasn't been fixed properly and that
there's a c door that just won't close
this represents the fault that Nolan
left in their life and how even though
things appear fine on the surface the
cracks are still there it's never going
to be back to the way it was no matter
how many vacations Debbie plans to take
a mind off it Mar on do them though
because of his responsibilities and as
they say with great power comes great
rice Uncle Ben's rice use the code Uncle
Ben's spoilers for 50% off at Uncle
Ben's
rice you son of a I'm in anyway
I'm sure everyone who's been forced to
be the man of the house can relate to
this because you very much feel like it
all rests on you even in YouTube I feel
like I can't take breaks cuz you never
know when this shit's going to end well
want to do is keep working while the sun
shines and Mark's refusing to relax
until he makes things right and back
with the Guardians we see is there
exhausted from the rig moral that the
Immortals being putting them through
Rudy ends up exiting his suit which is
reminiscent of the way that Tony does
during Spider-Man homecoming could
across to the locker room where we get a
play on season 1 when Adam Eve caught re
explode in the showers with Kate this
time around though the situations flp
with it now being Rex who's catching out
Kate the cheetah has become the cheaty
how the turn tables and I appreciated
how they changed up this moment from the
comics was issue 25 that had Rex coming
across them both but we didn't actually
see what was going on instead here this
is played like a flip on that initial
scene adding a real feeling of Rex being
on the other side of it okay is with the
immortal but a she she probably could
have two Ed them without anyone knowing
anyway at this point we could across to
Russ and also get some foreshadowing of
Aquarius We Begin by honoring Aquarius
king of Atlantis his death hangs heavy
over the episode and we also get a scene
that plays out in issue 31 that had Russ
watching the Guardians and seeing about
Martian Man Who of course was killed by
omn man in the first season realizing
that one of his people made a home here
he sets out to become a replacement for
him Aquarius is of course an Aquaman
parody in the series with the Guardians
being based on the Justice League in the
first season in comic we saw him Sat
board on his throne explaining why he
ended up going to the surface this
kingdom is something we see later on
with us also meeting his Queen now
returning Guardians is also thematically
shown in the next scene when we see Mark
heading out to tackle Darkwing the
original one was two killed by omn man
but someone else has risen up in his
place this entire segment here it plays
out in issue 21 with Mark investigating
his actions out in Midnight City we
learned that the midnight magician
turned it into a land of Eternal Night
after he cursed it back in 2002 now this
is when the original comic of that part
was released and I love how they gave it
that day in reference to that the
midnight magician also ended up taking
his own life and thus the city's been
stuck like this since the character's
death now Darkwing is of course a play
on Batman with a new one being his
Nightwing X sidekick that took over the
role there also the entire look of the
city and I'm sure you'll recognize this
as being like Batman the Animated Series
we can see that dark wings now went down
a brutal route though by the bodies that
hang up in the city the opening of the
issue that actually had him attacking a
woman whereas here we jump to the later
meeting happening on the roof in both
Mark arrived to find the brutal wake of
his destruction and we learn about how
night boy carried on his work Nightwing
Darkwing you can see the connection
there and he's lost his mind since his
mentor was killed off kids trained at an
early age to be like Robin they would of
course probably end up having some
issues which we see the character also
has too now in both the show and Comics
we see him using the same tactics with
him pulling mock into something that's
known as The Shadow V kind of reminds me
of the world that CLA kanders in the
comics and this pitch black Dimension is
terrifying to be in filled with monsters
Mark manages to get a hold of him and he
says I'm omn man's son you have no idea
what I'm capable of here in the shadow
verse we see the Dark Side of Mark
coming out and looking at his hand you
can tell he starts to question if he's a
good guy this was the same thing he did
at the end of episode one and you can
start to really sense the conflict
that's within him sense the conflict
that's with him sound like a bloody St
Star Wars character now from here we get
to Debbie who bites Cecil for drafting
him into being a soldier in his War
Cecil failed with what happened to his
father and though he promises not to H
Mark we know that isn't the case during
season 1 he collected his blood and will
likely have a backup plan so nothing
like that happens again startled to see
Donald all those her up to speed with
the comics will know exactly what's
going on and why the characters back a
pinky promised Amazon I wouldn't spoil
any future event I don't want Bezos
kicking me out the rocket when we fly to
beltrum the character goes on what's a
really interesting Arc and I'm sure if
you're that desperate to know then
you'll find out in the comments they are
playing things pretty close to the book
though so it's difficult a few times
something that you already know the
answer to I think the channels you know
the YouTube channels that haven't read
the comics they'll probably have a
better time with theorizing this stuff
but it's difficult for me to talk about
without out and out spoiling it they
have given Donald way more to do here
because originally the whole house
across the street thing was made up for
the show he wasn't killed during omn
man's Rampage age and thus they're
making it more closely attached to Mark
now at EES we see our parents are
struggling financially but they refuse
to put the burden on their daughter
whether that's down of Pride or the fear
that she might mess some things up the
relationship they have is very very
complicated if you watch the Adam Eve
special then you'll know she's not
actually theirs and this further adds
some interesting Dynamics to the
relationship Eve's dad's now working at
a burger Mt and we discover he lost his
job after omn man turned his last place
into Rubble Eve can just do whatever she
wants though and she makes a gold Apple
for them but they refuse to take
anything also wonder if this apple ties
in with her name Eve and it might be a
call back to the Garden of
Eden now this is a similar power set to
what Cersei had in the eternals with
both being able to manipulate things at
a molecular level this makes her one of
the most powerful characters in the
entire show but her positives are turn
negatives against her best wishes now
another character is trying to make a
difference is Amber who we catch down at
the homeless shelter taken to Las Vegas
by Mark it finally feels like we're
getting more of the uptempo fun stuff we
had back in season 1 this was before it
all turned to crap and marks very much
trying to just go back to those better
days Nolan of course also used to take
Debby on trips like this and we saw one
of those playing out during season 1 now
this really shows a difference between
him and his father because Mark mounts
up and goes out and does the work Nolan
on the other hand refused to step in and
he let Cecil's men handle it because he
didn't care and the rest of the
episode's taken from issue 15 and it
begins with Mark meeting up with cile
here he watches the storm ravages The
Cliffs whereas in the comics it was just
out at Cecil's headquarters in both
Mark's told that he has to marry a fish
to bury the hatchet but in the show
things start to differ he loves fish
sticks now with Cecil we watch as he
takes on the lizard League which are car
as to a main stage in both the show and
Comics these popped up at the start of
the Adam Eve special with Supreme lizard
now taking over King Lizard now the
lizard League that obviously somewhat of
a joke group with them being based on
the serpent society that comes from
Marvel Comics now it's during this they
meet cha Smith who also showed up during
this battle in the source material he
was also the one who managed to catch
seismic so they've kind of put these two
plot lines in the same episode even if
they're not connected but it's it's
still all connected either way it was at
this point they invited him in which
leads into what we see with the
character later now down in Atlantis we
see Mark being taken in by a ship which
is when he comes face to face with the
Queen the comics actually had him
somewhat going through with the marriage
with a consumation being planned to
happen after he took down the Titan this
would be in front of all the people of
Atlantis with them getting it on right
after the battle now in the comics the
queen and Thea that was known as lethan
who we found out was secretly in love
with her realizing that he was Mark's
only way out they hatched a plan during
the big combat encounter Mark made it so
it look like lethan took down the Beast
and then it seemed like he'd saved the
queen so the peir got it on this allowed
Mark to not have to fulfill the duty and
it meant he could go home and just
return to the surface here though they
don't want to do that at all and instead
nothing's going to happen with the
wedding what they want to release their
Beast known as the de dweller who we
kind of get a Finding Nemo thing with
where it's got a little little antenna
thing that seems like a cute creature
back with Debbie we see her about to
sell a home but she sees as the mailbox
won't close this reflects the door that
she's had put in her house and in both
instances they say it's been
professionally done up clearly hasn't
though you can tell theyve cut corners
and it just brings back the painful
memories that she's been suppressing I
really like what they've done with her
character in the season and she's
determined to get back on track and make
the most of her life she's not your pet
what was that this still clearly stands
as a sore point though and she mutters
it when when she sees how badly the guy
speaks to his partner clearly though he
doesn't view it as a partnership which
is very reminiscent of how Nolan saw
Debbie now whereas with Mark we watched
as he managed to get out on a
technicality in the show they do things
a little different Cecil's forces manage
to buy Mark a distraction which frees
the Beast and lets him Escape however
after it ends up going on a rampage he
returns to fighter and then save the
queen this helps to prove to mark that
he's not his father and somewhat makes
up for the destruction that the pair
caused throwing the depth dweller Back
Into the Depths marks pulled down there
too but he emerges out on top Alanis
calls it even because he saved their
lives but I kind of feel like Cecil
still doesn't trust Mark yet after all
he disob aror and is showing Cecil he
could still go against him Cecil ends up
pulling up the audio of the fight and I
believe he's trying to see if this
creature can be used against him we saw
how he broke out a similar tactic with
omn man and Cecil might be keeping this
in his back pocket now Donald's clearly
starting to suspect something's off and
this distrust also mired in the
character this this feeling that
everyone's detached from what's really
going on which is then M and he
returning home though she's trying to
see things from her dad's point of view
he puts her down and says that her
powers make it dangerous you can easily
see how the whole world would share this
sentiment too because so many lives have
been destroyed by the actions of them
Debbie just can't handle this either and
she ends up smashing up the cup door
repr presenting the broken home they
live in back with the Guardians we see a
shaped Smiths inducted into the group
with the immortal just welcoming him in
with open arms this kind of speaks to
the old school comic book mentality that
Heroes used to have in the Golden Age
with them like forming the Justice
League even though nobody knew anything
about the others at this point he starts
to lie about his backstory which is when
we cut out to Mars to see what's
happening this is kind of like what
happens during issue 38 with us seeing
the seid invasion as he tells us what
happened the astronauts were of course
terrify the seids who have come to Earth
and out on Mars we see as they've taken
over we end out their Ark with them
heading out into the stars and clearly
coming down towards our planet jump
across to the lizard League headquarters
where we also get a scene from issue 38
that had King Lizard stepping in and
shooting Supreme lizard which is exactly
how it plays out during this moment love
the way comes across them both and I
can't wait until we see what happens
with them further down the line anyway
from here we cut to the mid-credit scene
and see a version of Mark held up in a
machine this is obviously an alternate
universe where we see Donald and Cil or
well probably Donaldo and
Cilia I'm guessing that that's their
names anyway agrobs arrived to find out
how Mark was called how we discover they
did it when he was asleep sort of looks
a bit like a machine we see a certain
character hold up in later on which I've
got the editors to blur out because uh
you might not when that's spoiled either
way it shows Cecil's tactics and also
cements that he's able to take the V
tramites out now let angstrom know how
to defeat Mark and he's gained this
knowledge from traveling the Multiverse
knowledge was what he wanted to know
when traveling out of the Multiverse but
now he's using it for selfish means
instead of using it to help people in
his mind though he's still doing a
positive Crusade because he's ridding
the Multiverse of one of its most
dangerous people and all in all that
closes out the episode and this was
another really solid entry that pulled
so many bits from the comics as a
massive fan of them I love seeing how
they p it all together and thread these
bits into one cohesive storyline
everything is really kind of mounting up
and feeling like it's building towards
the themes in the show now this I think
it's all kind of built around what a kid
feels like after his parents get
divorced it's just that it's being
pushed to an extreme level something I
talked about with Simon ropa but
unfortunately the I went back and
watched the interview and it does spoil
some of the later episodes in the season
so I don't exactly want to drop that yet
but it is coming down the line now these
metaphors are definitely lace throughout
the episode though and seeing Debbie
watching the house falling apart really
speaks to how the character is now
feeling mentally there's also the new
people getting introduced like shap
Smith and the cool things like all the
threads being set up there's so many
things going on right now that pay off
massively down the line and I'm telling
you yeah it's exciting where it goes
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
make sure you're back next week and
please drop a like on the video as it
massively helps us out make sure you
subscribed as well and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out if you want
to get some heavy spoilers merch we've
got our t-shirt line located below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house of dragon stuff Marvel teas and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too and huge thank you to
everyone who's got one now if you want
something else to watch we've got our
breakdown from last week on screen right
now where we talked to Simon and kind of
went over some of the big themes huge
thank you if you're watching that I
really appreciate you guys getting us
opportunities like this and yeah all
your support it just means a will to me
now without the way I've been your host
Paul you've been the best I'll see you
next time take care
peace